so I'm really quite excited because
there's an exhibition outside here
outside my window in a huge tent for
conference of school teachers and
educators and Bradys been there already
and said there's a fantastic exhibit of
elements so we're going down there to
have a look together so come on I'm
excited to see it what we are attempting
to do is to create a periodic table
which has real lumps of every element in
there and to find lumps of every element
that are as beautiful as possible
it's litterateur well one of my
favorites is this one you can probably
work out from its position
it's osmium oh hi Mel - that piece
myself and I have melted much bigger
pieces than that but it's rather
expensive because osmium of course is a
trace contaminant of platinum you can
produce a lovely lovely solid lump that
shows the blue color if you look closely
and particularly if you compare it to
iridium which is equally dense or almost
equally dense can you see it's
distinctly blue I've never seen also
being like this before I've seen the
oxide sort of whitish pout crystals but
this is fantastic I won't steal it well
I'd be very happy to make a lump for you
in fact I'll invite you to our lab and
see something melted which is quite an
test quite a nice thing to see here we
produce a lot of elements in this form
of a cylinder and the reason we've
chosen this size is because of this now
this is one of my favourite lumps of
matter in the world and if you hold it
good
it's astonishingly dead as this the
tungsten yes and that has exactly the
same density as uranium and gold and so
that's as close as you most people will
ever get to understanding what it feels
like to hold a kilogram of gold with
Theodore gray
I thought it would be wonderful to not
just make a periodic table that hangs on
the wall but to make a periodic table
which has a beautiful lump of every
element in it and so for the last five
years we've been building periodic
tables and making them for universities
and schools and chemistry companies and
museums well this is this is quite a
well-known element silicon yeah but
we've got here silicon in a variety of
different forms so here for example is
silicon that I think has been reduced
from the oxide thallium thallium is a
very toxic element and even a few
milligrams of it can can poison you so
what we've done is in cases in a solid
block of acrylic right well I want to
see gold here we have a large surface
area of gold although I have to admit
the volume is not it's a bit feet turn
it on its side that is a nice piece yeah
how much is all the elements here worth
and then how much does it cost to buy
one oh well and it's all been made
artistically well let me first of all
explain that gold is the relatively
cheap element of fact and if one was to
compare its value with this element
which is quite close to it in the
periodic table up a bit that's rhodium
now rhodium is 10 times more expensive
than gold and at one stage last year it
became as expensive as $10,000 per ounce
so the cost of putting together a
periodic table is quite considerable we
make lots of different periodic tables
that the baby ones cost about $2,000 yes
the big ones cost about $20,000 this is
in the middle this one's probably around
about 10 or $15,000 $15,000 now that I
think is asked a team
and actually what's in there of course
is not astatine because if we were
looking at it we wouldn't be around for
very much longer but it's a piece of
uranium ore and they're on the nuclear
decay series there's an obscure side
branch that does occasionally produce
the odd atom of astatine yet that's the
best we can do
broke bromine of course much easier to
do I call this the Houdini element
because almost however you package it it
escapes I've not found a bottle that
will contain it permanently and even
glass even glass like to see the copper
and the phosphorus let's look at the
phosphorus now why haven't you got white
phosphorus well because we thought that
was one step too far at the ASE
conference to bring white phosphorus we
do have it of course in our lab in
London the most exciting part of
building periodic tables especially in a
school or in a university is takes about
four or five days to assemble all the
different complicated pieces and build
the cabinet and start filling them and
towards the end of that process you get
this most marvelous thing where people
come up to the table and if it's in
America it's just a constant chorus of
oh that's so cool and so to see the
enthusiasm and in many cases very
experienced teachers and scientists come
up and they've never seen a piece of
hafnium well they've never seen a even
sometimes a piece of titanium and so
it's really satisfying to I guess engage
people with the extraordinary elements
that make up our world
so there's hafnium good thank you very
much indeed and I think we will come and
visit you in your well standing
invitation and I can guarantee you some
fireworks